has been honing his craft for decades
it's a skill he learned from his parents
and other relatives
when creating his instruments he's
careful not to deviate from the
traditional design
this way he makes sure he preserves the
authenticity of each piece
i started making instruments to earn a
living but also to preserve our national
heritage our national identity because i
see that in cambodia people are not very
interested in keemer musical instruments
like his elders before him he's passing
down his knowledge to the next
generation
but he laments the fact traditional
cambodian music is no longer as popular
as it used to be particularly among
young people
[Music]
these days it's played mostly during
weddings and religious ceremonies
but some are working to preserve it
[Music]
here at the secondary school of fine
arts
students learn the khmer classical dance
with music played by a small ensemble
[Music]
needs some ladies all instruments have
special sound when we really listen we
can distinguish whether it's a strong or
soft sound in a dance performance
there are fierce characters and also
gentle and sad characters we have to fit
these sounds to the personalities
he says his father was also a musician
and taught him how to play
[Music]
cambodian music is an oral tradition
passed down from memory
it's only recently that the royal
university of fine arts started
transcribing the pieces
in a khmer traditional orchestra these
two instruments are normally placed side
by side this is the ronie egg it's got a
higher pitch and it plays the melody
whereas this is the ronie tong
and has a deeper sound and plays the
accompaniment
it's a rich tradition
a culture that goes back centuries
and these craftsmen
instrumentalists
and dancers
are ensuring it's kept alive
florence louis al jazeera phnom penh